il est entre le président de la
république et monsieur et monsieur
mélenchon
chacun se faisant la courte échelle on
voit ce que ça ça peut donner d'un côté
soit on aura un quinquennat pour rien
dans la continuité de ce qui a été fait
c'est à dire aucune aucune réforme des
mots soit le blocage du pays avec les
extrêmes parce que ce soit monsieur
mélenchon ou madame le pen ou bien
d'ailleurs que le programme économique
est rigoureuse rigoureusement le même
nous on a cette situation de jouer les
acteurs déterminants parce que on a la
foi et vous le savez des des candidats
qui ont un vrai ancrage territorial
différence des candidats en marche
notamment aidé des autres également si
vous êtes tous notés sur en marche
madame wargon qui pour se présenter dans
le val de marne mais des photos de lyon
on a aussi dans la 5e circonscription du
doubs un candidat qui met les photos de
la première circonscription quelques
quelques petits problèmes de de
géographie ou d'utilisation de de photos
anciennes
ce qui vient d'être annoncé par le
président de la république sur le
conseil national delà de leurs offres
aux fondations d'abord c'est un mépris
mais au delà du commun après avoir
méprisé
les élus locaux notamment les maires les
corps intermédiaires maintenance et ses
propres députés qui méprise leurs 10 ans
finalement peu importe tout ça n'est pas
très n'est pas très grave aux phrases on
freine
un tirage un tirage au sort et tout ça
ressemble à ce qui a été fait pendant ce
quinquennat ce la même nature que
lorsqu'il annonçait pour la réforme des
retraites
salle est l'équivalent de la création de
la sécurité sociale par le général de
gaulle on a envie de lui dire déjà un
peu d'humilité avant de se comparer au
général de gaulle et là il nous refait
le cnr si on reprend juste les premières
lettres dans le dans le même esprit
c'est le même esprit qu'il avait animée
au moment de la loi sur la laïcité nous
avait annoncé une grande loi sur la
laïcité pour finalement se féliciter
publiquement
l'attitude d'une femme voilée qui lui
expliquer qu'elle était qu'elle était
féministe dont l'enjeu des législatives
il est là ce qu'on veut dire aux
français aujourd'hui
les lois ce vote à l'assemblée le
président fait des annonces des discours
on a l'habitude d'entendre la réalité
c'est que les lois ce vote à l'assemblée
et que les députés les républicains qui
seront élus dans quinze jours sont
vraiment en situation de pouvoir faire
changer les choses encore une fois leur
ancrage territorial
la capacité à être force de proposition
jamais on a été dans les attitudes de
blocage à aucun moment les textes qui
vont dans le bon sens on sait les voter
on sait les améliorer ceux avec lesquels
on n'est pas d'accord on sait s'opposer
avec dureté et avec et avec fermeté et
on continuera dans cette dans cet esprit
voilà simplement les les quelques mots
que je pouvais vous dire mais ce qui se
passe
là depuis quelques jours est très
révélateur de
de risque de
dire d'inaction dans les cinq ans qui
viennent les événements qui se sont qui
se sont passées au stade de france sur
la sécurité ce qui se passe sur la la
santé aujourd'hui on pourrait parler de
l'école aussi d'ailleurs où sont les les
ministres le le ministre de la santé on
l'entend pas les pas qui c'est ministres
éducation nationale on peut le voir on
peut lire on l'entend pas
il y à vraiment la nécessité de faire
bouger les choses et on est en situation
de pouvoir les faire bouger pour les
cinq ans qui viennent
[Musique]